من الاسماء الفنيه اللي صارت جزء اساسي من
دراما رمضان والسنه الثالثه على التوالي
بنشوفها ضمن السباق الرمضاني وهذا الموسم
بتشارك في بطوله مسلسل
المتمرد هند بتلعب دور هديل لوصفتها انا
معتياديه ولا طبيعيه وقالت انها من اصعب
الشخصيات اللي قدمتها من خلال هذه اللي
بتكون لما طلب جمهورنا تعمل دور بعيد عن
البيئه الريفيه
علاقتي باصيل مو علاقه محاميه الموكمات
ولا تخلط الامور
انا الدنيا
يصير احب
واحب كل من يحبه
لا تريد السر الرجال حسب دكتور شخص واحد
على الاقل
بسرعه
هند نزار اهلا فيك معانا يا هند كل عام
وانت بالف خير
اهلا وسهلا رمضان كريم عليكم ان شاء الله
علينا وعليك يا رب هند خلاص صرتي من
اساسيات رمضان كل رمضان لازم نستنى عمل
وننبسط نحن نجيب لازم في تفاعلكم تطلعي
معانا
كل رمضان موجوده على الشاشه ان شاء الله
يعني ان شاء الله يا رب من نجاح لنجاح بس
هذه السنه نقدر نقول هند بنشوفها بطريقه
مختلفه الصراحه عن المرات الماضيه
نعم بصراحه يعني انا هم حبيت اشوف نفسي
بشكل جديد وشخصيه جديده يعني
دائما
الشخصياتها تكون الفقيره
والبنت الريفيه بس هالمره يعني انا هم
عجبني البس اشوف نفسي بغير ادوار وبغير
شكشخي والصراحه يعني شخصيه ما كانت سهله
يعني نهائيا
كان اول ظهور للشخص العالم كانت منتظره
والحمد لله والشكر لاصدقاء تجنن لحد الان
عليها امس كان كذا في دخول درامي
لشخصيتك ايش نتوقع في الفترات الجايه لانه
يعني انا وانا بتفرج اوكي في طبعا بطل
الملاكمه وفي البنت اللي بيحبها وبعدين
فجاه بتدخل علينا هند ايش نتوقع الدراما
حب دخول ايش حيصير
يعني كل شي تتوقعون هو راح يصير يعني ناس
البارحه الناس بدات تتوقع الاحداث انه
البنت تموت واني اجي اخذ حبيبها والناس
قالوا لا يعني هن زوجة واحد ثاني بالمسلسل
فاني حابه هذا يعني هذا التفاعل والناس
قالت انه اني طالعه شريره
يعني حابه كل هذه الاشياء وتقريبا فعلا كل
شيء هو متوقعين راح يشوفوه وجود داخل
الشخصيه بشخصيته اه والله حمستيني ايش
اكمل المتابعه لانه لانه حسيت انه كده انه
ايش في هند ايش حيكون وضعها طب هو اولادي
عنده حبيبه واحنا متعودين في المسلسل لازم
تنحبي
طالعه يعني اكيد تطلع فهمت تطلع حبابه
واحد يعني ايه لا ما دائما انت طيبه
شويه طيب بس خليني كمان اقول لك انه يعني
انت فعليا فعليا نقيتي العمل عشان تطلعي
من موضوع خلاص هذا البيئه الريفيه ولا انه
صدف وجالك هذا العمل ولا عن قناعه انت
اخذتي مصاري مختلف حسيتي انه خلاص
بالكتابه والكواليس فقلنا انه اتمنى انه
اني واني هم اقترحت انه اتمنى انه اكون
بشخصيه محاميه او
لانه يعني كان ببالي هذا الدور انه هو راح
يتناول قضايا او ملفات نفتحها نسائيه من
هذا الباب اني كنت رايته رايده انه محاميه
وتدافع عن النساء او عن المراه برافو الله
لمن انكتب يعني اجاب هذا بهذا الشكل وهذا
اللي انا يعني
بس اكيد ما يخلى من الحب ومن
العذاب والاكشنات
يعني
لازم شويه شي زين انت تقولي لي اها انت
تحسي ان المراه مظلومه فحابه انك انت يعني
تاخذي او تعملي ادوار فيها رساله عن
المراه
يعني هذا اللي دائما احاول اوصله من خلال
كل عمل اقدمه بكل دور الي احاول انه يكون
به رساله تخص المراه والحمد لله بالاعمال
اللي فاتت يعني هذا الرساله كانت موجوده
المراه مثلا خصوصا المراه العراقيه
يعني
دائما تنظلم من البيئه ومن العائله مرات
يعني اني انقهر لما يكون هو الظلم متزوجها
او يكون من اخوها او يكون من ابوها هذا
هذا يعني انه اذا هم هذول اللي المفروض
يكونون سندها هذولا يكونون عليهم فهي شلون
راح تواجه مجتمع كامل فهذا اللي اللي اني
دائما اشوفه بمجتمعنا للاسف وهذا هم وحده
من الملفات او يمكن ملفين بقضيه هديل راح
تدافع عن عن وحده عن هيك قضيه يعني نسيت
تريدي
بدات ايه
يعني من ملف احنا نف
تحه
واغلبهم للاسف حتى بالنص مكتوب انه فعلا
هم يعانون من اللي داير مدايرهم ومن
المجتمع
الفتره الاخيره بس على الاقل يعني شفنا
انتعاشه
للاعمال العراقيه يعني قبل كم سنه كانت
الاعمال العراقيه خلينا نقول قليله محليه
جدا الان ويمكن كمان ام بي سي العراق لها
دور في هذا الموضوع يعني صار في انتعاشة
بتحسي بهذا الموضوع
شوفي الحمد لله والشكر اني يمكن اول بارحه
بيني وبين نفسي اقول الف الحمد لله والشكر
انه
الدراما العراقيه من تعشه ومنطلقه بشكل
كبير يعني حتى مو محلي الموضوع يعني
الموضوع عربي يعني
المسلسلات تشاهد عربيه الحمد لله والشكر
فهذا الشيء يفرحني وام بي سي عراق هي
يعني اقدر اقول وكل ثقه انه هي وضعت هذا
الحجر الاساس للمنافسه ولدخول او رجوع
الدراما العراقيه فهذا مو غلط وهذا بالعكس
التنافس اني احبه والغيره الشريفه بالشغل
هي موجوده ولازم تكون موجوده وحلوه لما
تكون موجوده يعني اني افرح اليوم لمن اكو
بنات وياي موجودات بغير ام بي سي عراق
وداخل ام بي سي عراق وبغير قنوات هم
يشتغلون حتى تكون اكو منافسه لما تكون اكو
روح منافسه كلنا راح نحاول نبدا وكلنا راح
نحاول نطلع اجمل ما عدنا فبالعكس هذا
الشيء فرحني وابارك للجمهور العراقي
وللعائله العراقيه واقول لهم انه خلي شويه
نبتعد عن الانتقادات لانه الجمهور العراقي
يهجم فشويه شويه خليه يشوف هوايه اعمال
بعدها ما طالعه وهوايه اعمال بعدها ثالث
حلقه او رابع حلقه احنا اليوم برمضان
فخلينا نشوف وخلي ندعم لان هو ما يعرفون
ايش قد كواليس الاعمال هي شقد متعبه وشقد
ممكن واحد
من وجهه نظرهم بيقولوا انه هذه الاعمال
يمكن سيئه او تسيء للمجتمع او مش عاجبهم
التمثيل
انا بقول لك الكلام اللي بينقال
هلا
شويه سريعين بالحكم مو على عملي انا اقول
ولا يمي الموضوع صوره عامه سرعه يعني
اتمنى من الجمهور انه بس انت كمان يا هند
على طول هجنوكي
بس اني يعني والله ما عندي مشكله بالموضوع
الحمد لله والشكر يعني مستمره واذا اقدم
بنفس الوقت اذا هاجموني عشره بالمئه فاني
عندي 90% ناس تحبني اذا هاجموني 20%
اكو ناس تحبني ثمانين بالمئه فاني دائما
هند عاليه
وتسعين في المئه
الحمد لله والشكر يا ربي الحمد لله يعني
اني هذا الشيء ما انسى هذا هذا العراقي
اللي قدم لي اياه وهذا جمهوري العراقي
اللي انا ما اقدر انكر حبه وفضله علي بانه
انا وين اكون وهند وين هي اليوم هذا ولكن
لا زالوا الى الان يمكن هذه النقطه انا
تناقشت فيها مع اكثر من وجه عراقي من اللي
اصبحوا الان بارزين وبياخذوا بطولات اعمال
يعني في انت طبعا في مثلا الكسندر علوم في
كذا احد انه كثير ناس بيقولوا انه طب هم
ايش خبرتهم ياخذوا بطولات الاعمال
ويتصدروا الساحه الان لازال هذا الكلام
بيتكرر رغم انك صار لك الان يعني ايش ثالث
سنه في رمضان
اعمالك الاثنين الباقيين نجحوا وتصدروا
المشاهده بيزعجك هذا الشيء نعم
يعني شويه يرجعون
على البدايات او التاريخ انا يعني خلاص
هاي فرصتي واستحق اليوم اخذها اني صار لي
عشر سنوات بالوسط من 2013 او 2012 فهذه
فرصتي اني استحقها واني عندي دراسه يعني
جايتها وحتى اللي يجيها يعني حب تكون عنده
موهبه لكن انا هذه فرصتي واستحقها واستحق
اليوم اني اكون موجوده واستحق اني اللي
اخذ البطوله هذا يعني هذا مكاني الحمد لله
والشكر
فماما خذته من احد ثاني بنفس الوقت
فرصه للشباب ولوجوه الجديده ما بيها اي
مشكله او خلل انه وجه جديد اللي بيه اللي
عنده هذه الموهبه ويحملها وحريص على الفن
ويقدم برساله فاهلا وسهلا بيه يعني احنا
ما عندنا مشكله ويا اي احد يدخل جديد او
وجه جديد او لاول مره يمثل هند انا
المهنه ويحترمها انا بدي اقول لك حاجه انا
معجبه جدا بردك على هذا السؤال انا اعرفك
من سنين واحبك على مستوى شخصي جدا لانه
اعرف انت قديش شخصيه يعني طيبه حبابه وكل
هذا الكلام يعني وخلال السنين تطورتي انا
جدا حبيت الان انك انتي قلتي انه انا
استحق وانه انا استاهل وانه هذا مكاني
يعني يمكن هذه واحده من اكثر الاشياء
النساء عندهم مشكله فيها انه دائما يشكوا
في نفسهم يسمعوا للانتقادات وكذا كثير
حبيت انك انت لا عارفه قيمتك
الحمد لله والشكر يعني لازم كل واحد يكون
عارف قيمته حتى لان هذا استحقاقنا يعني
ساره منو يجي ياخذ يعني المهنه من عندنا
واحنا اللي يعني مقاتلين حتى ناخذ هذه
الفرصه اليوم ونكون موجودين
فانا جمهوري احب كلامه اذا بالسلبي واذا
بالاجابه فاني اسمع من عنده واحبه
واتفاهمه واتفهم انه هو يعني قاعد يريد
يستمتع ويريد يشوف عمل درامي يستحقه وخلي
يكونون على ثقه كل الفنانين مو بس اني
اليوم احكي بكل فنان عراقي كل فنان عراقي
حريص على انه يقدم
شي نظيف مهم
محترتك وانا تعرفي يا هند منحازه لك دائما
ولنجاحاتك بالتوفيق دايما كانت معنا
النجمه هند نزار شكرا لك يا هند